[Music]
[Music]
my name is Jeff Sankofa I'm a PhD
student and african-american studies and
American Studies and I study 20th
century policing in prison what a talk I
gave today was a chapter of my
dissertation called delinquent migration
and what I'm doing is tracing young
people left on began working between
ages 9 and 15 and trying to better
understand how their migration journeys
might differ from the traditional
narrative and what's very interesting
about these young people is that they
were not the heads of household they
often traveled alone they had to find
food and so what I'm also trying to map
is sort of the development of like
professionalized policing and sort of
how does like policing
impact their migration patterns when
being a delinquent or being young it's
actually a crime why Creamery were like
part of the photo and also every story
maps and also like experimenting with
video which was like through so what I'm
trying to give a documentary and sort of
tone to the website and so the larger
digital storytelling website will be
like on one hand mapping story mapping
but on the other hand being able to like
interact with whoever's watching it with
like short documentary stories about
their lives in charges like newspaper
articles or other records like census to
put into like a visual story all it's
awesome I mean reason I say awesome
because I actually never really thought
about DX method and I just kind of came
in with a project on migrations and so
I've kind of run into the DHL add like
in three classes and so when I seen it
there was these resources that can help
me with the project I just kept going
over to DHL lab like weekly and then I
got a digital humanities feed grant and
that helped me with sort of having
someone work with me on data input cuz
there was some die action I still don't
know how to do as much as putting like
geographical locations into an excel and
transferring actor like story mode and
so that was like great thing to do
so this is my Square to dat oh yeah so
my name is colin haymer's I'm an
undergraduate junior studying art
history and biomedical engineering and
so I'm here to sort of present a project
that I've been thinking about pertaining
to there's a way that scientific imagery
operates and artistic so what I've been
asking myself recently is how the
scientific imagery operate in artistic
and cultural spheres how do artists sort
of pick on pick up on the kind of
imagery that scientists produce and an
interesting case study of that has been
the imagery that's produced out of the
nuclear weapons testing era here in the
United States between 1945 and 1963 lots
of imagery videos photographs were
produced lots of new photographic
techniques were developed and and lots
of new sort of philosophies and ways of
thinking about photography where were
kind of arose and artists sort of picked
up on that in an interesting way so I
can explain that
I'm Paulie third person here and was a
coursework dad in algorithm commuted
composition the benefit of Alberta music
is you can define you can get unexpected
music even the composer didn't expect
but you would want it still to sound
pleasing and we thought one framework
for freezing with the harmonic varying
directional and cohesive so we developed
a framework where we have module systems
that's quite stimulated jazz ensemble my
name is John Hartford I work at the
Center for teaching and learning and
we're working with Babylonian collection
to showcase a throne room at NIMH routed
by Adi are for people to experience so
the background of this project came
about from our interaction with Annette
Lawton who's in the Babylonian
collection here at the library she was
interested in bringing students into a
VR setting to view objects that were
destroyed by Isis in the in the home era
ruin material the project came together
very quickly and we partnered with a
firm
Massachusetts that constructed the
throne room at NIMH report and we're
we're bringing art art history students
through this space to for them to see
and witness some of the relief that you
see scattered across museums and
exhibits all over the world be collected
together and in the location where it
originally existed so that they can see
it in the context of the room that that
those objects existed in and get a sense
of space and life its system I mean Wow
all I can say is Wow
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]